[Musique]
c'est la première vidéo dans le nouveau
décor les amis première vidéo dans ce
nouveau décor est ce l'occasion de
tester un nouveau format un nouveau truc
on va lire des threads
qu'est ce que vous en pensez d'avoir
tout changer pour faire la même chose
qu'avant vous en pensez quoi mais on
dirait que ces nouveaux du coup comme
rien n'a départ et qui abandonnent vrai
ça fait longtemps que je suis méchant
être moi même ça fait à peu près à moi
je crois qu'on n'a pas fait de ce raid
horreur la dernière fois on était passé
sur le let's not me it sur reddit et
montgailhard les histoires un croyant
plus c'est vraiment des gens qui
écrivent ce qu'ils ont vécu aujourd'hui
laissez moi vous raconter trois
histoires vraiment horrible pour ceux
qui ont vu la vidéo cet homme vous savez
ce qui va se passer ces moments de
passer en mode ce raid horreur ça marche
bien
la première histoire s'appelle la femme
de l'hôtel mais qu'elle et ses collègues
étaient en déplacement pour le travail
et du coude en mai dans un hôtel le soir
mais un jour en rentrant à l'hôtel
michael il a eu une énorme surprise dans
sa chambre lezat collègues rebecca
marcher tranquillement dans les couloirs
de l'hôtel et mickaël en ouvrant sa
porte il voit quelqu'un dans sa salle de
bain alors premier réflexe c'est dans un
hôtel généralement il peut y avoir
quelqu'un en sachant qu'on t'offre ta
porte de chambre et c'est souvent
quelqu'un qui fait le ménage sauf que
miguel constate que ce que cette femme
tient dans ses mains c'est pas du linge
qui traînait ou quoi que ce soit c'est
son sac à dos pourquoi quelqu'un qui
vient pour faire le ménage aurait dans
ses mains ton sac à dos dans sa salle de
bains par réflexe il lui dit bonjour et
la personne ne répond pas et fait comme
s'il n'était pas mais qu'elle se tourne
alors vers sa collègue rebecca qui est
en train d'entrer dans sa chambre donc
la chambre d'en face de celle de michael
et lui dit rebecca ya une femme dans ma
chambre
à partir de là faut dire que michael est
il en état de choc c'est à dire que il
rentre chez lui comme il a fait plein de
fois dans sa vie dans sa chambre d'hôtel
sauf que là là quelqu'un qui est dans sa
salle de bain et il est sûr à 99% que
c'est pas du tout quelqu'un qui est là
pour faire le ménage c'est quand même
terrifiant comme situation il se
retourne alors vers la femme qui est
dans sa salle de bain et lui dit qu'est
ce que vous faites avec mes affaires
dans vos mains la femme laisse tomber
son sac à dos et sort de la chambre avec
son sac à main elle dans la main et un
sac en plastique et mickey à lui reprend
un peu ses esprits il lui dit y'a quoi
dans le sac en plastique
elle ouvre le sac et montre un michael
est effectivement aucune affaire amical
dans le sac mais que celle de la femme
michael toujours en état de choc laisse
partir la femme de la chambre et il est
complètement sur le cul il comprend rien
ce qui vient de lui arriver
normal mais qu'elles rendent dans sa
chambre et tchèques à gauche à droite
voir s'il ya des affaires à lui qu'ont
été volée très bon réflexe est bizarre
tout est là son pc son portable tous ces
appareils électroniques les trucs qui
sont petit et qui valent chers sont
toujours en place et ils n'ont pas été
pris par la femme il va alors ensuite
dans sa salle de bains à voir s'il
manque des choses parce que c'est là
qu'était la femme au vent il a pris en
flagrant délit problème mais qu'elle a
un traitement contre je sais plus quelle
maladie bref il ya des médicaments qu'il
apprend tous les jours et il était dans
sa salle de bain et ils ne sont plus là
elle les a volés mais qu'elles courent
alors vers la sortie de la chambre pour
rattraper la dame elle est pas dans le
couloir il fait le tour de l'hôtel il va
à la buanderie tchèque le hall d'accueil
tchèque partout plus aucune trace de
cette mystérieuse femme il se rend alors
avec rebecca à l'accueil pour témoigner
de ce qui vient de se passer et pour
appeler les flics pour dire voilà y
avait un trou dans ma chambre quelqu'un
a essayé de me voler retrouver le lien
emblème en attendant que la police
arrive et retour dans sa chambre avec
rebecca pour continuer sa petite enquête
à lui et voir s'il manque des affaires
ou pas et y remarque qu'il ya sur son
lit une batte de baseball en métal et il
ya une lampe de poche qui est accroché à
l'extrémité de la bat
quel est cet accessoire étrange pourquoi
incombe aussi bizarre à part peut-être
taper des gens dans l'obscurité
rien de rassurant en tout cas rien du
tout de rassurer un peu de temps après
la police arrive sur les lieux il se
rend dans la chambre de michael et y
prenne sa déclaration est celle aussi de
rebecca qui a été témoin de tout ça
michael remarque alors un truc très
étrange que dans l'évier de sa salle de
bain il y à des morceaux de cloisons
sèches peut-être que c'est des morceaux
du plafond qui sont tombés parce que
l'hôtel est un peu vieux mais bon au
plafond n'y a pas de traces d'usures
donc a priori c'est pas ça
les policiers mais qu'elles vont plutôt
essayer de trouver le chemin par lequel
elle est arrivée dans la chambre
est ce que c'est une fenêtre qui a été
cassée est ce que c'est une porte qui a
été enfoncée est ce qu elles étaient
cachées sous l'île sans qu'il s'en rende
compte depuis un moment et ben que dalle
la porte est dans un état nickel les
fenêtres pareil on sait pas comment ils
arrivent ils vont alors demander à
l'accueil de l'hôtel si c'est pas
possible qu'elle ait trouvé ou garder
une carte plus vieille de la chambre et
que la carte marche toujours parce que
l'hôtel au bled à désactiver ou un truc
à la con comme ça l'hôtel est formel
non c'est impossible officiers présents
sur les lieux va appeler deux autres
officiers en renfort pour essayer de
retrouver la femme dit qu'elle est
encore dans les parages mais ça donne
rien que dalle donc qu'ils ont juste
pris la déclaration michael et ils sont
partis michael va alors se poser sur son
lit et passer des coups de fil pour
raconter ce qui s'est passé il vient de
vivre un truc très chaud quand il
repense à cette histoire de morceaux de
cloisons sèches dans l'évier et il se
dit mais saisit un truc qui va
pas avec ça c'est bizarre il a le flair
il à le faire les meilleurs à specter
que nous n'allions pas de femmes il
retente dans la salle de bains regarde
les morceaux cloisons sèches lève la
tête regarde le miroir qui a en face de
lui et d'un coup nous
ricard il décroche le miroir du mur et
derrière le miroir se trouve trop voilà
c'est la photo la seule photo cas dans
le thread de michael c'est celle là est
mon gars ça fait froid dans le dos le
trou il fait pile la taille pour que
quelqu'un s'y glisse quoi les policiers
étaient encore sur le parking de l'hôtel
michael il va les chercher il leur dit
écoutez je crois que j'en trouve un bail
là c'est indécent venez voir vite les
policiers montent ils inspectent dans le
trou et il trouve un oreiller des
couvertures des cigarettes des vêtements
une brosse à dents la mystérieuse femme
que michael avait vu dans sa salle de
bain vivez en fait de l'autre côté du
mur dans ce de trous y avait en
fait un espace entre le mur de la salle
de bain de michael et le mur de la
chambre voisine
un espace que michael décrit comme
faisant environ deux pieds donc un
espace d'environ 60 cm pas très large
mais suffisant pour que quelqu'un s'y
glisse et dorment là et axa une chambre
d'hôtel quand la personne qui a loué la
chambre d'hôtel n'est pas dans la
chambre d'hôtel michael explique ensuite
que ce qui ouvre c'est que ça devait
faire un bon moment qu'elle était là
parce qu'il avait déjà été en
déplacement à cet endroit là ils avaient
déjà dormi dans cette chambre d'hôtel
plusieurs mois avant et il avait senti
une odeur de cigarette dans sa chambre
mais il avait pensé comme tout le monde
que c'était peut-être dans une autre
chambre que quelqu'un fumée dans la
salle de bain et que la fumée était
arrivé dans sa salle de bains à lui par
les aérations vous savez tout est un peu
relier mais non mais qui ajuste une meuf
qui fument et de l'autre côté du miroir
dans ton mur tranquille et quand tu
partais elle sortait du mur et l aller
faire une petite sieste dans tous liés à
toi bien plus confortable que le siècle
et elle prenait des choses dont
millibars peut-être même qui ces mecs
c'est horrible c'est tellement bas dans
en vigueur il c'est de se dire ya
quelqu'un qui était là depuis tout ce
temps tout près de moi vraiment dans mon
espace intime et j'ai rien aux plats à
plein de gens coopèrent de dormir à
l'hôtel prochainement moi y compris bon
il est temps de passer à la deuxième
histoire qui est tout aussi bas dans tu
m'aimes plus bas dans ton corps je
trouve c'est la pire situation mais elle
est différente c'est pas la même
mécanique a envahi laissez moi vous
raconter l'histoire de lucie et maxime
qui était au supermarché avec leurs
enfants et tout est parti en couille
tout a commencé par le bébé qui
commençait à s'agiter à crier dans tous
les sens à pleurer pour le plus grand
plaisir des gens qui font leurs courses
non nouvelle pièce dans un avion en vol
supermarché on s'en fout dans l'avion
c'est un peu dur mais on a tous été
comme ça alors on peut rien y faire
c'est faux c'est fou ce jeu télé par le
hublot
ils disqualifient tout a commencé par un
petit caprice du bébé vous savez c'est
un bébé il est assez petite phase est
donc maxime le père l'a pris et l'amener
sur le parking pour pas déranger les
gens qui faisaient leurs courses en
maxime et respecte bien les gens lui
l'individualiste m'y connais pas à lui
c'est le monsieur parfait mois le bébé
pleure je regarde les autres joueurs
ch'est sais ce qui t'attend comptera un
enfant chez apprécié mentalité de merde
maxime la mène donc dans sa voiture sur
le parking pour lui faire faire un petit
tour c'est ce qui endort beaucoup les
bébés moi même je crois quand j'étais
petit ma mère faisait ça pour m'endormir
voilà il en avait que pour 10 minutes
donc l'uci est resté dans le magasin
itunes et faire les courses mais elle
voyait ce qui se passait sur le parking
mais alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé sur
le parking très bas dont une femme
marche vers maxime qui se tient bien
droit dans la trentaine taille moyenne
bref rien d'affolant en apparence tout
l'inversé
elle te met complètement en confiance
précision importante l'uci qui raconte
l'histoire nous indique que c'est pas
rare que des gens viennent les voir pour
poser des questions sur le bébé jouer
avec leur bébé et c'est ce qui explique
pourquoi maxime n'a pas réagi en mode
affolé tout de suite les siestes de ce
bébé étant très importante maxime
s'apprête à dire à la femme que non ça
va être possible de jouer avec lui mais
la femme s'approche avec une démarche
déterminée et avant même qu'ils puissent
terminer sa phrase la femme prend le
porte-bébé dans lequel se trouve le bébé
et 120 watts maximum restent sous le
choc
il faut quelques secondes pour réaliser
ce qui se passe est ce que quelqu'un
vient vraiment en plein jour de prendre
mon bébé eaux calmes il dit alors à la
femme de poser le porte-bébé avant de se
mettre un peu à paniquer quand même ça
fait un peu peur mais la femme reste
calme et continue de s'éloigner
maxime se met alors un peu a haussé le
ton à lui dire d'arrêter tout de suite
et poser le porte bébé et à mesure
qu'ils se met à parler de plus en plus
fort elle se met à marcher de plus en
plus vite il se décide enfin à taper un
gros sprint pour la rattraper
sauf que le porte bébé est temps devant
elle il est juste apporter de ses bras
nom qui lui attrape le bras et là le
pire au moment de sa vie la meuf se met
à crier et elle dit aidez moi s'il vous
plaît ce mec essaie de voler mon bébé
appelé le 911
non elle lui met un coup dans le tibia
et elle sort une gazeuse de son sac à
main le réflexe vraiment comme si une
femme était agressée pour de vrai et
qu'elle cherchait à se défendre
sauf que là c'est elle la kidnappeuse et
lui il a rien fait c'est son bébé c'est
horrible de tous les gens du parking
n'ayant pas vu ce qui c'est passé juste
avant il se retourne et voit une femme
avec une gazeuse dans l'âme inquiète
bien habillés qui est propre sur elle
qui est un porte bébé et à côté de ça il
voit un mec avec un tueur deadpool c'est
lui qui le dit ce n'est pas moi
n'ayant pas le contexte et vu l'urgence
de la situation il
jette sur michael et une le mettre à
terre c'est pas le truc le plus injuste
est horrible c'est pas toi le méchant de
l'histoire et tout le monde croit que
c'est toi c'est horrible les gens
conseil à la femme qui a volé le bébé
d'aller porter plainte de ne pas laisser
michael sont punition et la femme sort
son meilleur jeu d'acteur elle joue
celle qui est bouleversée qui réalise
pas ce qui vient de lui arriver et elle
dit non non je veux juste rentrer chez
moi et oubliez ça je veux juste rentrer
chez moi laissez moi merci michaël
lavoie alors ouvrir la porte de son
minivan la voiture la moins rassurant du
monde finalement la voiture complètement
clichés du kidnappeur d'enfants vraiment
c'est celle là et les gens continuent en
attendant la police de maintenir michael
au sol bloqués comme ça il peut pas
bouger il voit son bébé partir au loin
avec cette femme
il peut rien faire à part crier et dire
que c'est lui le père et que c'est son
bébé tu veux que personne ne le croit
voyant michael s'agitait l'un des hommes
qu'il tient lui mais deux ayant coupé
dans les côtes et save a fait les deux
côtes à michael qui est en train de
faire voler son bébé se retrouve en plus
avec des coûts de ptc communiqué en
sortant du magasin lui si elle tombe sur
son mari qui est maintenu au sol par
plusieurs personnes et elle croit
d'abord qu'il entrait en fait de se
faire racketter elle se met alors à
hurler sur les gens à leur dire de
lâcher et en tournant la tête
elle voit une femme qui tient son porte
bébé sûr qu'elle va croire que la femme
a en fait sorti le bébé du danger pour
pas qu'il lui arrive quoi que ce soit
lors du rac étage de michael le
quiproquo de l'enfer russie ne trouve
pas le gars qui gère la sécurité à la
sortie du magasin alors ils se
précipitent vers les gens qui sont sur
michael est leur dis prenez mon
portefeuille prenez tout ce que vous
voulez mais laissez le en dehors de ça
foutez lui la paix est là l'un des mecs
quitté michael lui dit madame on doit le
maintenir le temps que la police arrive
lucie elle dit alors pourquoi les mecs
qui rackettent mon mari aurait appelé la
police aucun sens
elle leur demande alors à leur dis mais
pourquoi pourquoi la police qu'il a fait
exactement je ne comprends pas et les
mecs qui tiennent michael au sol lui
répondent
il a essayé de kidnappé le bébé de cette
femme et d'un coup elle comprend elle
comprend que son mari s'est en fait fait
voler le bébé est qu'en voulant arrêter
la femme les gens l'ont pris lui pour le
kidnappeur elle se met à chercher autour
d'elle la femme qu'elle avait vu juste
avant qu'ils portaient le porte bébé
elle aperçoit de l'autre côté du parking
elle tape son meilleur sprint vers elle
elle utile qui perforent les cheveux à
tel point que la femme laisse tomber le
porte bébé elle se jette sur le porte
bébé pour le recouvrir et que plus
personne ne puisse toucher à son bébé
la femme est alors monté dans son
minivan elle est partie et personne et
c'est de l'arrêter personnes l'injustice
de toute cette situation le quiproquo de
toute cette situation est absolument
horrible tout est horrible c'est fou le
savons vraiment que quand on voit une
scène mais qu'on n'a pas le contexte
qu'on a pas ce qui s'est passé avant
qu'on peut complètement se tromper sur
la situation c'est vraiment horrible et
à cause de ce truc là ce couple-là ce
jour-là a failli se faire kidnapper leur
bébé quand même c'est ouf ils ont vécu
un truc parfaitement injuste et horrible
est bon ils se sont mis depuis mais
c'était très traumatisant les explique
lucie explique ensuite qu'il sont
rentrés chez eux et qu'ils ont juste
pleuré pendant des heures avant d'aller
chercher leurs trois autres enfants à
l'école et de faire comme si rien de
tout cela n'était arrivé voilà morale de
l'histoire il n'ya pas de morale
un truc de merde tu peux toujours te
tomber dessus c'est le pur hasard et il
faut juste savoir agir pour te sortir de
cette merde et voilà bref plein de
bisous à lui c'est mickaël qui ont vécu
un enfer même s'ils sont pas du tout
français et qui ne verront jamais cette
vidéo rêve troisième et dernière
histoire qui est bien plus courte mais
très bas d'août
alexandre explique qui vit dans un
quartier assez difficile qui vit avec
quatre colloques mais que cette histoire
s'est passé pendant les fêtes de noël et
donc il était seul chez lui il a reçu
pour noël une sonnette qui contient une
caméra et en fait quand quelqu'un sommes
tus reçoit une notification et tu peux
voir du coup qui a sauvé grâce à la
caméra cas dans la saône est alexandre
la dengue attaché sur l'encadrement de
sa porte les jours passent quand le
facteur sonne pour livrer un collier
reçoit la petite notifie voit la tête du
facteur il est content tout marche à
merveille tout se passe bien sauf qu'un
jour ils rentrent du travail et la
sonnette n'est plus là on lui a volé il
est un peu deg mais d'un autre côté il
est pas surprise dit bah oui c'est
évident qu'un objet cool comme ça jusqu
au tce à ma paroisse bape si un mec vous
le volet il peut très facilement le
faire il explique ensuite au moment où
il raconte cette histoire que la veille
au soir
quelqu'un a sonné sur cette fameuse
somme est même si je le rappelle elle
n'est plus devant sa porte
elle est toujours connecté à son
téléphone il ouvre l'application et la
vidéo apparaît et c'est sa maison pour
moi le mec qui avait volé la sonnette
était là juste devant la maison d'alex
et filmé la maison d'alex avec la
sauvette d'alex tout va bien alexis
panique un peu surtout qu il explique
que c'est un quartier où il se passe pas
mal de trucs pas cool et que lui-même il
s'est fait voler à gaza une fois et d'un
coup l'image de réplication re devient
noir comme si le voleur la sonnette
venait de la remettre dans sa poche
alex se précipitent va sa fenêtre pour
voir s'il ya quelqu'un devant chez lui
sauf que personne n'était le mec a
probablement eu le temps de se barrer
entre temps mais juste c'est horrible un
mec tu voles ton truc et des jours plus
tard et filmé tout chez toi avec ce truc
c'est pas le début d'un film d'horreur
c'est horrible n'achetez pas de soudaine
c'est bien tout qu'est regardez regardez
ça marche bien oui à quel cas les amis
c'est la fin de cette vidéo serait du
coup on peut repasser sur des belles
lumières lumineuse voilà
c'est quoi je commençais un peu à me
chier dessus parce que l'améliorer il
est 20 heures passées j'ai mis toute ma
langue connectés en rouge suis dans le
noir je me suis un peu dessus
j'espère que ces trois histoires vous
ont plu j'ai c'est comme d'habitude à
chaque fois trouver des mécaniques
différentes que ce soit pas toujours la
même mécanique qui fait peur ne vous en
faites pas vous n'avez pas besoin de
vérifier derrière le miroir comme del
rey dans une chambre d'hôtel je vous
jure y aura pas de trous y aura pas de
personnes dans le mur sauf si vous
tombez sur la chambre d'hôtel que ce mec
avait loué je ne dirais pas qu à l'hôtel
ceni où il est venu à gaza
c'est fou je me répète mais c'est fou
comme là il s'agit pas de tout pas
normal de fond tous beaucoup assez juste
des gens qui sont faits les quoi et ça
peut tellement de tomber tous dessus
c'est super bah non je suis bientôt dans
une prochaine vidéo
c'est bon vous allez mal dormir pendant
deux semaines puis ensuite y aura de
nouveau trois ce nous allait bientôt
d'eau avant la prochaine vidéo sur des
scènes d'horreur je vous laisse sur une
obscurité avec une touche de rouge et 28
ans
allez ciao
[Musique]
il